[Music]
this is where the money printing comes
in
quickly pushing money pushing my money
into the system
well inflation is when the value of your
dollars just doesn't go
as far is simply defined as more dollars
chasing less product
right now the price of lumber now you
can see we just don't have as much
lumber in circulation
and the price of lumber is going up okay
now there are a couple of different ways
that inflation happens one is just that
there's actual under supply
just there's some sort of fallout in the
industry it's the price for the product
is too low the other way
is that the government starts injecting
so much money into the system
and so now the prices naturally go up
what this does is it devalues savings
this means that your money that was in
the bank
it is not worth as much money it's
supposed to spur spending but this can
create an inflationary cycle
because now you want to take all your
money out of the bank and spend it
before it is worth nothing
what you are really doing is taking
savings and making them worthless this
is why you see all these pictures from
weimar germany of people wheeling around
wheelbarrows full
of cash now we don't do that anymore
you're not going to see people
wheeling around wheelbarrows filled with
million
dollar bills that they just kind of are
wallpapering with
so the basic theory is that some
inflation is not only natural but good
in the normal way an inflation curve
looks it looks like kind of a wave
okay milton friedman suggested that you
wanted to basically look for about a two
percent inflation rate
in order so that people didn't take all
their money and put it in the bank you
wanted there to be a little bit of
inflation so that people would continue
to spend and put money
into the economy sometimes the demand
for a product outstrips the supply so
prices go up
but in a functioning free market economy
that increased pricing
will actually drive people to enter the
business and increase supply so the
prices drop back down
there are basically two different
departments of the government
that are designed to control inflation
one is the treasury department
and one is the fed the treasury
department actually prints the dollars
but
typically that's not how inflation works
the federal reserve these are the guys
who are really in charge
the federal reserve controls how much
money banks are required to hold in
reserve
every night so you've seen the movie
mary poppins
remember the heather's run on the bank
but everybody goes and wants their money
out of the bank at the same time
the bank doesn't have the money they
have to close their doors
[Music]
so what happens if a bank gets to the
end of the day and it hasn't held enough
money in reserve
well then at the end of the day they
borrow from another bank at interest
that interest rate is what we call the
fed fund rate
the fed sets the rate they buy or sell
securities from the member bank so
here's the bank down here
the fed will go to the bank and give the
bank credit
going that way and the bank will give
the fed securities
[Music]
all the security is all a bond is is
basically a promise
that i will give you money right now and
you will return that money to me with
interest
since last march the fed's fund rate has
been at zero which means easy money
money basically the fed is just allowing
banks
to take money out from the fed at zero
percent interest and then the banks are
charging you really low interest rates
if you're wondering why it is that your
home mortgage rates
on the market right now are really low
that is the reason it's because the feds
are basically making it super easy for
banks to lend to you
okay the second way that the fed
manipulates the currency is through open
markets
operations the fed will buy lots of
securities from the member banks and
then give them credit
same kind of thing that we saw before
right here's the banks the fed
will send them all sorts of money they
will buy
all sorts of securities from them at
zero percent
and then they just keep giving them
credit right more and more and more
money
more and more money right we're just
gonna shovel money into the banks
right this is what the fed is doing so
where exactly
did the fed come up with all of this
credit
nowhere the answer is nowhere they just
make it up it's all electronic
so no dollars are actually created
physically when the fed does a lot of
this is called quantitative easing
we saw a lot of this during the last
recession we're seeing a lot of this
during this current
recovery and recession the federal
government
sells these bonds if the market is soft
and the government needs to spend money
the federal reserve will simply buy
those treasuries from the primary
dealers
right so the question is where are the
banks coming up with these securities
the answer is that the treasury
department plays a shell game
the treasury is selling to primary
dealers these banks
and then those dealers are passing those
up the food chain to the fed and they're
getting cash in return
the treasury department may have to pay
back the bonds one day but the federal
reserve has injected cash into the
system via the treasury department
so here's where we are right now
inflation is setting in
thanks to both the federal reserve's
inflationary monetary policy and the
biden administration's massive spending
binge which is funded by the national
debt
remember when the biden administration
sends out checks it is sending them out
via the treasury department
the way the treasury department gets its
money is the treasury department sells
bonds
who's buying the bonds the banks who's
buying from the banks the fed right
sometimes it's coming from foreign
sources sometimes these bonds are going
out to china
right and that creates national debt
sometimes the bonds are going out to you
directly
but if you really need to inject a lot
of cash super fast what you do is you
sell them
to these primary dealers which very
often are the banks and then
those get passed up along to the fed
right now the federal reserve is holding
nearly seven
trillion dollars in bonds these are
securities mortgage-backed securities
other assets presumably at some point
the bonds and securities will indeed
have to be paid off
right now the fed is owed a bunch of
money by the treasury department the
good news is this is where the money
printing comes in
who's got the printing press these guys
got the printing press right
in the meantime the federal reserve has
run out of stimulus tools you've got
inflation
which is you've got the pricing going
like this and demand instead of
coming up to meet it which would drive
this down on the other side
supply and demand curves are supposed to
look kind of like that instead the
supply curve is going to go like this
and what happens with the prices they're
going to continue to go this way as long
as the government pushes it so this is
when you get stagflation
now the problem is the entire theory of
inflation from the federal reserve
is that the way that you stimulate
demand is by giving people more money
if they have more money they have more
money to spend but what happens when the
demand
isn't there because people have decided
they're going to take the money and
they're going to put it in the bank
because they don't trust
that their dollar is worth anything so
no matter how fast they spend they can't
keep up with the inflation rate and they
don't have a job
so what exactly happens at that point
well that is when the pain sets in
because at a certain point
the federal reserve has no more tools
when they're already at zero what do
they do in europe they've actually tried
to go to negative interest rates which
is kind of crazy that is literally
the federal reserve paying the banks to
take the money right you could try it
you can't do it forever
inflationary cycles with stagnation are
generally breakable only through pain
and given the current inflation rates
payne could set in a lot sooner than we
expect i'll be honest with you
i thought that the natural economic
recovery that was set to happen
after covet was going to last at least a
couple years and it would take a little
while
for joe biden's crappy monetary policy
to catch up with us instead we're
getting
record inflation rates like the worst
inflation we've seen in 40 years
it's pretty astonishing how fast all the
bad policy caught up to americans
janet yellen who's the treasury
secretary she keeps saying that
inflation is just going to cool off so
what they really hope happens
is that this follows the normal rules of
supply and demand that yeah we're
inflating the currency
and yeah there's a little bit of a hold
up here
but eventually supply is going to go up
to meet it and then you'll get the
normal supply demand curve right then
you'll get the
the you'll get this the problem is
that there's no guarantee that that
happens especially because of the
artificial shortage of labor that is
being created here
it means this line is not happening
right now
the inflation rate this month was
something like four percent
well normally if you can ramp up supply
to meet that four percent inflation rate
okay this is gonna go down again and
that's sort of what
janet yellen and company are suggesting
and they're saying okay well if we have
to
then we'll raise interest rates and
we'll start to suck money out of the
economy
and maybe that'll bring down the
inflation rate a little bit but the
problem is there are two numbers that
matter
one is the four percent the other is the
266 000 jobs
that were created last month okay that
was supposed to be
one million jobs okay this gap
is really devastating what it shows is
that even though we are blowing money
into the economy and
in some ways because we are blowing
money into the economy specifically by
paying people to stay home
there is this gap between the ability to
ramp up the supply
to meet the demand and that's how you
end up with stagflationary cycles
what is the long-term solution of this i
mean the truth is that the long-term
solution to this
is a gold standard right the long-term
solution is what we abandoned a long
time ago
the abandonment of the gold standard was
a way for government to take control of
the monetary supply
and the disconnecting of the american
currency from the gold standard and from
international gold rates
when that happened we completely
disconnected the dollar from anything it
is not connected to anything except the
full faith and credit of the united
states so whatever the hell that is
worth
all men and women created by the go you
know the
you know the thing the real answer would
be
you know some sort of asset that is
disconnected from the ability of
governments to manipulate the currency
which is why you are seeing rising
prices of bitcoin
this is the reason you are seeing that
there are two theories of what happened
during the depression one is that the
federal reserve
created to loose a monetary policy this
is sort of the vienna school of
economics
they say that there was a stagflationary
cycle that set in basically
where the federal reserve had blown too
much money into the economy there was
too much speculation on the basis of
crappy assets
and the bottom fell out of those assets
and then there was a bunch of
follow-on legislation from the federal
government that really made things a lot
worse there was trade legislation
that killed international trade there's
high taxation rates
high spending rates and that really
exacerbated what should have been a
short-term
sort of depression then there is the the
milton friedman chicago school of
economics and they say almost precisely
the opposite
they say that the monetary supply was
too tight and that what happened is when
the depression hit
and stocks lost a lot of their value
banks should have immediately
been pushing money back into the system
that there wasn't enough money that was
being pushed into the system so
there's a bunch of different arguments
about exactly what happened during the
depression and they have almost
precisely reversed consequences
what is what is generally agreed on by
free market economists is that the
government coming in
raising tax rates removing capital from
the system on behalf of government
spending
and raising tariffs was a disastrous
decision it's hard to know whether we're
heading to a full-on great depression
at this point i mean right now obviously
the job market continues to grow
what what is certain is that things are
not going the way that we were told they
were going to go
and so that means that we have a couple
of different paths here one is you enter
a stagflationary cycle that looks a lot
like the late 1970s
with randomly high unemployment and very
very high inflation rates with savings
that are basically becoming devalued
over time
the other one is that you do get a
full-on depression in which people
basically sell off their assets but
i i don't really see that happening in
an inflationary cycle this way
that seems hard to hard to imagine and
the other is that maybe
we just come out of this and that's sort
of what joe biden is hoping at this
point
there may be some whistling past the
graveyard because again these inflation
rates
are much higher than we were told they
were going to be